Instructor: Another
feature of template literals or
template strings is the ability
to do multiple lines without any
funny business. What I mean by
that is, the funny business is,
previously we had to do things
like text = you say hello there,
and you want a new line. Say how
are you... You see my text
editor is freaking out here
because I have entered onto a
new line and we have to fix it
by doing a forward slash and a
forward slash and a semicolon
there. That gets to be quite a
task, to be able to do that.
Instead, we can now use template
strings. I'm going to say markup
equals, and where I like to use
these multiline strings is just
when I'm creating HTML markup
just as a string. I'm going to
give myself two backticks here,
and inside of that I'm just
going to go ahead and mark up
some of my HTML that I need here.
I need a div with the class of
person. Inside of that I want an
h2 tag. Now, I want to go ahead
and put the person's name right
inside of the h2 tag, so we just
use dollar sign, curly brackets,
person.name. Then maybe
underneath that I would also
like a span. I'm going to put
these on their own lines here. I
want a span with a class of job.
Inside of that we'll say person.
job, then below that we want a
paragraph with a class of
location. We can pop in the
location here, person.city. We
can also do the same thing with
the bio. You can see how
this is so much nicer. We will
get this white space here, but
we don't really care too much
about that because we're just
creating HTML fragments. Now,
I can take this string and go
ahead and dump it into an
existing element. I've just got
a blank page right here, so
there's nothing. The only
existing element that we have on
the page is the document.body,
and then I'm going to set the
inner HTML, but this could be
any...You could use document.
createElement, set the inner
HTML, and then append that to
the body, whatever you like.
Same with markup. When I
refresh the page you see "Wes,
web developer, Hamilton, Wes is
a really cool guy." If I inspect
that, you'll see it's all been
processed as proper HTML without
having to do any document.
createElements. Pretty nice.
One other thing, let's just
console.log this markup just to
show you that the new lines are
there. You can see that all of
the new lines, all of the tabs
and the spaces are included as
part of that string. Another
amazing feature of template
strings is that you can nest
them inside of each other. What
does that mean? What if I have
an array of dogs and I want to
loop over and get myself a list
item for each one. Let's
just say const markup equals,
and we'll give ourselves a new
line here, and of course we want
a unordered list with the class
of dogs, and inside of that I
want a list item for each one.
But I can't, I can't just do
like dogs.name because that
would be cheating and that's not
really scalable. So how would I
loop over every single one?
How do you loop over things? We
can nest template strings right
inside of it. How do we do that?
Let's take a look here, we can
give ourselves a $.map,
and you can use an arrow
function here, which is dog, and
for each dog you want to return
a string. Whoa. Here we are
getting a template string inside
of a template string, so when
you go ahead and return that
template string, we're going to
return a list item, we're going
to close that list item, and
inside of that actual list item
we are going to give the dog.
name is and we're going to say
how old they are in dog years.
We'll say dog.age times seven,
that's how old you are in dog
years. Now we've got all this
markup here. Let's take a
console.log, see where we're at.
Snickers is 14, Hugo is 56,
Sunny is 7. Now we have this
comma here, how do you get rid
of that? Well, map will return
an array, we can simply just
join it together with nothing,
and that will just join it
without the comma. Now we can
go ahead and say document.body.
inner html = markup, or
whatever element you like to
dump this markup into, and
that's going to dump it right
onto the page for us. That's a
good example of, if you need
looping inside of this, then you
can use a map function.
Again, you could do this on
their own lines if you prefer to
do each on their own lines and
indent it. This is just much
more maintainable, to be able to
read some HTML like this. You
don't have to worry about your
white space or anything else
like that. Let's look at an
example where we need an if
statement inside of our template.
This is taken straight from how
you do if statements inside of a
react render template, and that
is with a ternary operator.
Here I've got a song, some data
with a name and an artist. We
always have a name of the song
and the artist of the song, but
sometimes we've got a featuring
one. If there is a featuring, we
need to say brackets, featuring
Biggie Smalls. Let's code the
first part first. We'll have a
div with a of song, and inside
of that is a paragraph, and
inside of that we can give song.
name m-song.artist. I've
already set that to the body
here, or whatever element you'd
like, and give it a refresh, and
we see "Dying to Live" Tupac.
Our HTML is working fine. Do you
see that? It looks kind of funny
here if you look at it. We've
got all of these white space,
and that's because we've got all
this white space here. But it
really doesn't matter, because
the white space is ignored as
soon as it hits the HTML.
But, that said, what about when
we want to have the featuring?
If we have the featuring, we
want to have a bracket,
featuring song.featuring. Save,
featuring Biggie Smalls. That
works, but what if we delete
this? Featuring
undefined. If it's not there, we
don't want the parentheses or
the word "featuring," or
anything there. A way we can get
around that is by using a
ternary operator. A ternary
operator will say if this then
that, otherwise nothing.
We'll say if there is a song.
featuring, then we want to give
ourselves some backticks with
that whole string right in there.
Otherwise, we'll just give
ourselves nothing, two blank
quotes. What that should do now,
is featuring Biggie Smalls, but
if we take it off entirely, the
featuring is gone entirely.
That's a nice little way to do
an if statement right inside.
The last couple of examples were
pretty simple, but what happens
when your data starts to get a
little bit complex? You can see
nesting, inside of nesting,
inside of nesting, starts to get
a little bit hairy and hard to
maintain your code. What I like
to do is create what I call a
render function. I've sort of
taken that from react, where we
create separate components that
will handle different complex
data and different components in
our markup. Here I've got the
beer name and the beer brewery,
and that's pulling into an h2 in
a paragraph, and it's looking
pretty good here. But what if I
want to implement this array of
keywords that's nested inside of
the actual beer here? I could
just go ahead and do the map
right on one line, but I'd
rather kick it off to a separate
function. What I'm going to
do is put a dollar curly
brackets and say, render
keywords. It's a function. I can
just run a function inside of
one of these, right inside of my
template tag, and I'm going to
pass it the beer.keywords.
Then I can go up here and make a
function called render keywords.
That's going to take in the
keywords and it's going to
return to us some backticks, and
inside of that we give ourselves
an unordered list, and then for
each keyword I want to say
keywords map. It's going to give
us the keyword, each individual
one, and that is going to return,
again, another template string
that has the key word inside of
it. Now this function should
just be able to pass it off.
It's only one line, and it
should be able to create the
unordered list, and the list
item, any other HTML that we
need to have created inside of
this. Get a refresh. Pale,
cloudy, spice...Oh, what's this?
We forgot to do the join after
the map. Join it on nothing, and
that will be gone. Let's
take a look at our HTML here.
We've got our unordered list
with all of the list items
inside, and you can see that any
time you need to render out a
unordered list of keywords,
whether it's tied to this beer
or not, I can simply just call
render keywords and get back the
markup that I need for that.